Okay, so let's get started on actually solving this problem. We've
got to remember that the first step in our procedure is
to extract the complete list of carriers and the complete list
of airports from one example page. So, what I've done here
is downloaded this page and I'm simply going to parse this
page in order to pull out both these lists. So let's
take a look at some code. Now, what I like to
use for parsing HTML is BeautifulSoup.
In particular, we're using BeautifulSoup four.
You can download and install BeautifulSoup on your own machine
using any one of a number of different package managers.
I like to use PIP. If you don't already have
BeautifulSoup installed, just Google for
installation instructions. Now, what BeautifulSoup gives
us the ability to do is parse the document tree,
the HTML document tree in this case. And, it's similar to
elementary for parsing XML. Okay. So let me walk you
through how this code works. So what I've done is I've
set this up so that it's the options function
that does the bulk of the work. I'm calling
options and note that what I'm calling it with
is this soup value. And soup is what I
get in response to having called beautiful soup on
the local file that is a saved copy Of
this one. In addition, I'm passing this string CarrierList.
Now what BeautifulSoup passed me back was the top level
element for this particular HTML document. And then what
I can do is I can use the find method
here. The meaning of this is find me the
the first descendant element in this document tree where the
ID attribute for the element is CarrierList. Okay? So
let's go look at the HTML, and see why we
wrote it that way. Okay? Again, I can get
to the HTML by using the Inspect Element feature of
Google Chrome. Okay. So here's the CarrierList, and note that the ID attribute
for this particular element here is CarrierList.
Okay, so CarrierList, then, will have the HTML element that we
just looked at as its value. Then what I'm going to do is call Find all
on CarrierList. Find all does something very similar
to what find does. It finds the descendants
that are option tags or option elements. Now unlike
find, find all will actually find all of the
sentence instead of just the first one. Okay, so
here what's going to happen is I'll just iterate through them
then, and I'm going to just build up a list
of all of the values. Now what I'm actually doing
here Is finding each one of these in turn
and I'm pulling out the value of their value attribute.
Because, it's this value that I need to pass in any subsequent http
requests for data having to do with, say, air Tran or Alaska airlines. So
that's how we get the carrier data we need. I use a very similar
process, in fact it's an identical process,
for getting the full list of airports.